autre mesure qui était annoncé par le
gouvernement fort dans le dossier des
francs comtois c'est le théâtre la
nouvelle scène une institution
francophone à ottawa qui ne recevra pas
une subvention qui avaient été promises
pourtant par les libéraux de madame
swing de 3 millions $ pierre antoine
lafon simard
un des administrateurs de ce théâtre est
au bout du fil
pour nous en parler monsieur qu'est ce
que ça représente ce théâtre-là cette
salle de spectacle à ottawa puis en
ontario la nouvelle planète un lieu
historique dans la culture
franco-ontarienne c'est le lieu de
résidence de quatre compagnies qui
couvre un public de zéro à 89 ans et ce
depuis plus de 40 ans d'histoire
certains des grands noms du théâtre eux
mais nous québécois aujourd'hui il n'en
fait lord arme je pense à brigitte
heynckes michel marc bouchard anne marie
cadieux pour ne nommer que c'est un lieu
d'une importance capitale et qui rayonne
partout au pays et qui accueille aussi
le meilleur des arts vivants que ce soit
en danse en théâtre et ce depuis de
longues années est d'abord et avant tout
c'est un lieu de rassemblement pour la
communauté francophone à ottawa mais
partout ailleurs aussi c'est vraiment le
lieu pour la francophonie la culture bon
je vous emmène dans le vif du sujet s'il
manquait trois millions de dollars pour
boucler le budget comment se fait-il que
si c'est si fugace et si beau si
importants qu'on nous venons de
conscience que c'est parce que nous
venons de terminer un grand processus de
rénovation complète du bâtiment
c'est ce sont des dépenses qui sont
normales dans les contextes comme
celui-ci s'était donc sept derniers 3
millions peut-être partie d'un processus
naturel gouvernement qui nous avait donc
fortement qu'ils avaient donc promis cet
argent pour finir de boucler ce cycle
d'ailleurs face au succès du contenu du
lieu alors il s'agit évidemment d'un
d'une d'argent qu'ils iraient
directement à l'infrastructure et donc
la surprise est totale d'ici et surtout
ce désaveu complet d'un gouvernement qui
depuis des années on l'a vu sous mac
avis semblent toujours tirer sur les
trois co phone dès qu'ils cherchent une
victime à mais comme dans le passé comme
on l'a vécu avec mon fort il peut
rentrer des francophones et des artistes
francophones sur son chemin il faudra
suivre ce dossier là
aussi alors monsieur simard merci
beaucoup je vous remercie bonne journée
au revoir